first on cbs this morning cece sabathia
joins us
live in studio in the table we're so
glad when new people come in so we
welcome you
welcome can i just say you grabbed me
from the very first line of the book
because it starts out with
i'm a weird alcoholic which immediately
made me think what exactly does he mean
i want to read this book what did you
mean
yeah it was just one of those things
where i could detox myself so like um
i would pitch and then the next three
days i would drink
so the day after right after i came out
of the game i would need a drink and i
would drink the next three days
and i would take two days off pitch and
then do it all over again so i
kind of had a routine where i would
normalize drinking for three days like a
bender and then i would detox myself
be able to pitch it and then do it all
over again but you seem to think
in the book do you seem to think that
this was very normal behavior
yeah i mean for me it had become very
normal and it was just
part of my routine and so much so that
when i went to rehab i came out and i
was thinking like how am i going to do
this without alcohol because that have
become so much a part of my routine that
yeah i mean it was
it was a part of you know my pitch and i
felt like you know cece in the book
you don't sugarcoat anything you i mean
there were jaw-dropping moments a lot of
times and you were so candid
i mean even when i was reading the piece
you know about the jay-z party and your
wedding night
i i felt kind of choked up saying it out
loud
but yet you sat here and watched it
because you seem now to be able to tell
the story with no fear and no shame
yeah i mean it's no problem for me to
tell the story and like i told you
before
i had normalized all this stuff so for
me you know people
read the book and it's jaw-dropping
stuff but for me it's just my life and
it's normal
and i didn't think people would think it
was interesting or or fascinating it's
just
you know something that i had dealt with
and knew that i was alcohol dependent
from the first time i had a drink when i
was 14 years old
when you had your first drink when i had
my first drink and and just had dealt
with it and
and kind of like i said just normalized
everything and you know just
kind of went on at my at with my life
you know alcohol depending and just
trying to deal with it my favorite page
was page 215 when you make the decision
to go to rock
to go to rehab you said everybody's rock
bottom is different
what was your rock bottom that made you
say okay enough because you had done
all sorts of stuff leading up to that
yeah i mean i think it was just me
waking up
um realizing that you know i couldn't
stop that weekend in baltimore you know
it was three days where
i just couldn't stop i wanted to stop
drinking and i and i couldn't so
you know i didn't want to waste right
before the game this was right before a
game and i didn't it was right before
the playoffs i didn't want to wait until
i heard somebody or
i had a dui or i was court ordered to go
to rehab
you know i wanted to get in front of
this and make sure that i was doing
making the right decision
for my life because i'd always put
baseball in front of everything and at
this time i needed to put my
kids and my family um and my health
in front of in front of my career i feel
like you had to be really strong to do
that though
because you're going to the playoffs
there's a lot of people in your life
saying
can't you just wait don't come back
don't tell me you know what there were a
few people in my life saying that but
then
the most important people were like no
if you if you need to go
get help get help brian cashman joe
girardi your wife
my wife um amber was was you know she
was huge into that
um chris young dealing with all these
people
that you know that mattered in my
baseball life were like no you need to
go get help so that made it easy to go
make that decision cece you've been
sober now for nearly six years
what has that journey been like and what
would you tell other people out there
who see someone like you
who have you know the money you have a
beautiful family but yet you were still
battling this addiction i think that's
why i wrote the book i wanted everybody
to understand and that's why i got so
candid in my details is i want everybody
to to relate to be able to relate to it
and
you know you can't have all these things
all the money and all the stuff but
still
you know struggle with mental health and
be alcohol dependent and but you can't
get help
you know the the the toughest thing
about you know dealing with alcohol
dependency is reaching out
and saying that you need help and and
that you and that you can't fight this
alone
um since i was able to do that the last
six years have been great you ever
i just want to say something about amber
honest to god
i wish amber was here
she was a truth teller in your life she
really i mean she put up with a lot no
question about that
what did her support mean to you and i
mean do you think you could have
you could have survived what you
survived without her i was so
blown away by her as well yeah
absolutely not there was no way that i
could have
navigated my career without her um
obviously
you know being being married for 20
years and being in the game you know her
career now being an agent but just every
i mean her support meant everything
to this day still i mean you know her
support me and my family and
the kids the the support that i get from
them um
it just it lifts me up it's just
everything is what keeps me sober
you talk about her a lot in the book and
how she had to clean up a lot of your
messes
always still to this day now
you also talk about the struggle for
black men in this country you said
listen being black in this country it's
a stigma
uh for black men to seek therapy because
we think of weakness as a vulnerability
and that's one thing that you wanted to
do to say that you need to get help when
you need to get help yeah it's one of
those things in our community where we
don't speak up or talk about you know
alcohol dependency or even you know
mental health so
you know for me to struggle with this
for a long time and and not feel
comfortable enough to to get help
i mean i like i said i knew i was had
this problem when i was 14 years old
but i'm trying to fight it alone and do
all these different things where
probably should have reached out in my
20s and i kind of could have got it
under control so
i want people to be able to watch my
watch my documentary watch the story
read the book
and just know my story to be able to get
baseball guys
you were a really good baseball in
between all of that
baseball player well that's are you
hoping to inspire some of the people in
the league because you talk about how it
is a problem there are a number of
alcoholics in the league
yeah you know what what i told gail that
this this morning is that it just
the the those competitive um
environments just breed that that type
of
you know it just helps fuel that type of
um
those type of dependencies you know if
you have alcohol dependent and you're in
a heavy stress environment
you know you're going to lean on those
substances so um yeah i mean i want to
tell my story
and be super open so that if people need
to reach out if they're struggling
i can point them in the right direction
or even you know help them myself
i'm sitting here looking at your left
arm because your left arm becomes a
character
from the streets of vallejo around the
yankees can we get a picture of your
left
hand honestly what does baseball mean to
you sabathia
cece before we leave it's meant
everything like you said i mean my arm
is has taken me from
vale california to this desk you know
and it's the places that i've never
thought
i'd be able to reach and and uh you know
it's just been a blessing to be able to
to uh you know have it until the end you
know it was it was like the interesting
part of the book
until the end refers to his arm his arm
was there till the end
thank you so much for coming i i think
your book will help many i think it's
like jamie said very brave and
courageous to tell the stories that you
did
in the detail that you did thank you
cheering you on always
always the book till the end goes on
sale tomorrow wherever you like to buy
your books